[Música]
la revista de prensa en directo américa
de françois 24 me acompaña en el estudio
rosa pérez más de borrosa bienvenida muy
buena mañana de martes vamos a abrir
esta revista de prensa con una imagen
icónica de esta ola de calor que
alcanzan temperaturas récord en europa
pero vamos a empezar con reino unido
buenos de a raúl efectivamente se trata
de una fotografía de jones y blake para
la agencia reuters en la que vemos a los
míticos particularmente a un guardia de
la reina no los que digamos guardan el
palacio de buckingham en londres al que
le da agua otra persona no un poco
representando esta ola de calor en reino
unido porque básicamente si éstos
aguarda se asoman por un lado conocidos
porque es prácticamente imposible
hacerles reír o hacerles reaccionar
también lo son a por sus uniformes no
que bajo estas a temperaturas extremas
podemos suponer que son aún poco
insufribles en todo caso recordemos que
son a soldados del ejército británico de
infantería lo que impacta de esta
fotografía que ha sido elegida por
distintos medios de comunicación en sus
portadas alrededor del mundo es que sea
eso otra persona la que le ofrezca el
agua en todo caso repasemos los
titulares que acompañan esta impactante
imagen por un lado del 'times' de reino
unido dice un calor loco detiene trenes
y deshace pistas de aterrizaje
recordemos que ayer se suspendieron
durante unas horas los vuelos en el
aeropuerto londinense de luton
precisamente porque se deshacía la pista
de aterrizaje por este calor es factura
de ti exactamente no porque ayer
recordemos fue el tercer día hay más
caluroso de la historia de reino unido
por otro lado the daily telegraph
también a temperatura récord caos en los
transportes las escuelas cierran y hará
más calor y es que precisamente lo que
hemos venido comentando se esperan hasta
41 grados en el territorio británico por
otro lado también el financial times
dice reino unido se prepara para más
calor efectivamente o el 'new york
times' la ola de calor que tiene el
reino unido- y es que los trenes ayer
también a sufrieron importantes retrasos
porque los conducían especialmente de
una forma especialmente lenta
evitar que se dieran los raíles o que se
rompieran los cables no raúl así es de
rosa y como siempre estas condiciones
extremas como una ola de calor afecta
sobre todo a las personas más pobres y
precarizadas en cualquier parte del
mundo pero no nosotros vamos a ir a
madrid en españa porque indigna la
muerte de josé antonio gonzález rosa que
hay sobre este caso vendaval pues es un
caso digamos que se puede extrapolar a
muchos lugares del mundo también se
habla mucho en la prensa británica no la
necesidad de proteger precisamente las
personas que trabajan en la condiciones
más duras y es precisamente lo que
relata el periodista manuel viejo en el
país no como las condiciones laborales
precipitaron la muerte de josé antonio
gonzález un hombre de 60 años que murió
a las 5 de la tarde del pasado viernes
cuando estaba trabajando como barrendero
en madrid donde hacía más de cuarenta
grados bien lo que sucedió es que este
hombre tenía un contrato de un mes un
contrato laboral de un mes y esto es
precisamente lo que denuncia a su hijo
que comenta en este artículo que siempre
llegaba destrozado a casa su padre dice
se queda consciente de que esto le podía
pasar pero lo hacía porque quería
conseguir un contrato largo estoy
convencido de que él no paro de limpiar
esa calle hasta que se desmayó pensaría
que no le iban a renovar y estaba
dándolo todo con tal de demostrar que
valía bien su hijo pide una mejora de
las condiciones laborales para todos los
trabajadores del sector básicamente con
estos uniformes tan pesados y trabajando
en horas del día intempestuosa además la
cuestión es que a pesar de ser un
servicio municipal este está
externalizado a una empresa que se llama
urbaser que gestiona la limpieza de las
calles de madrid por lo que el
ayuntamiento se digamos limpia se saca
de encima las responsabilidades de esta
muerte y de otros accidentes laborales
bien en todo caso su hijo también
preguntado por el periodista relató que
la última búsqueda que hizo su padre en
el ordenador fue que hacer frente a un
golpe de calor no algo que precisamente
da peso el argumento del hijo diciendo
que su padre podría esperar que esto
sucediera que no paro de trabajar por
miedo a que le echaran oa que no le
renovarán el contrato
porque además pues la necesidad y
evidentemente un arriendo una familia
comida y pues las consecuencias
continuamos con otra portada la
liberación en francia que ayer abordamos
porque comentaba también la
imposibilidad de rosa de apagar el fuego
que arde hace ya una semana en el bosque
de pinos de gironde en el sureste
suroeste del país exactamente como bien
decías ya son más de 30.000 las personas
evacuadas son a miles las hectáreas
arrasadas por estos a fuegos y
precisamente lo que titula la liberación
es la sensación han de estar en una
película apocalíptica no y precisamente
por otro lado vemos en una crónica en el
interior de este medio una imagen
bastante reveladora en un raúl porque
vemos en una playa muy cercana a la
mítica donde pilar cuando desde donde
pues es un lugar bien turístico y desde
dónde se ven estos incendios ahora la
vamos a ver a continuación vemos a los
bañistas
digamos un poco
revelando esta frustración que podemos
sentir a nivel individual aquí detrás la
tenemos frente a una cuestión que es sin
duda una problemática estructural no
este modelo digamos económico este
sistema que hemos digamos permitido que
pasará por encima de todas las
advertencias climáticas desde hace años
no y un poco está digamos impasibilidad
más que nada esta frustración
esperando a que digamos se tomen
acciones desde las políticas un poco
regulando el sistema económico y
precisamente esto es lo que relatan los
bañistas en esta crónica dicen las
personas en el poder no son suicidas
hasta el punto de no reaccionar bueno
vamos a ver por otro lado dice la
crónica en la playa las personas de
vacaciones están inquietas por los
fuegos descontrolados a pocos kilómetros
y esperan que la catástrofe hará sonar
la alarma para luchar contra el
calentamiento climático sin embargo raúl
no sabemos si esto hará sonar
definitivamente la alarma porque para
terminar rápidamente en el wall street
journal
la unión europea espera que el
suministro vital de gas ruso no se
reinicie según lo previsto y
precisamente esto que es lo comenta el
comisario europeo de presupuesto
johannes hahn está llevando a que la
unión europea se plantee como digamos
como decíamos ayer este plan llamado
ahorradas para un invierno seguro que
levantaría las restricciones de las
emisiones contaminantes incluso
subsidiaría el carbón en todo caso no
sabemos si el invierno será más seguro
como plantea la unión la comisión
europea en todo caso nuestro planeta
probablemente no lo será nunca más claro
y si vemos un verano seguro seguramente
el invierno también rosa gracias por
toda la información seremos en esta
primer invitada al día